the spider-man far from home trailer is
fittingly putting the web in a spin
whilst the trailer does a pretty good
job of conveying what the main plot of
the film will be I actually think that
there's a lot more going on beneath the
surface now fans of the wall crawler are
already well aware that Mysterio is one
of spider-man's main villains in pretty
much every comic that he has appeared in
he has been an adversary to the webhead
and it seems strange that far from home
would pitch him as an ally that appears
to be working for shield in the trailer
we witnessed him arrive during one of
Hydra man's attacks and take him head-on
it's clear the other elementals that
appear in the trailer will be the bad
guys but what if this is a ruse an
illusion created by Mysterio in order to
receive fame and fortune Mysterio is a
master magician illusionist and keen
expert in hypnosis so this is not
outside of his abilities personally I
believe that he has merely manifested
the monsters in order to swoop in and
save the day he's done this before as
well and fans of the ps/2 spider-man 2
game will no doubt remember in that when
he defends by the man in pitted himself
as the savior of New York what if he is
doing the same thing here and using this
platform for personal gain
to me the most glaringly obvious pointer
of this comes in the fact that the film
has far too many villains if this is not
the case we all saw from spider-man 3
that three villains leads to the movie
feeling overstuffed and imbalanced Sony
would surely not make the same mistake
again instead it seems more likely that
these are ruses put in place by the
character in order to appear like a
legendary hero obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this theory and
whether you agree or disagree with my
take make sure you leave them in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of the entire trailer which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]